there's miss me oh yeah hey Tom how are
you brother alright so we'll start off
with that first question should people
make news people should make news
resolutions if they're actually watching
this video on January 1st if they're
watching it on December 23rd
they should make December 23rd
resolutions waiting miraculously to win
the calendar flips to start making your
life better is silly at best and pisses
me off at worst and so whenever you're
watching this because it lives on the
internet and thus that means you could
watch this on June 17th 2017 make a
resolution every day of your life
because you only get one at-bat the
reason people struggle with having a new
year's resolution and sticking to it is
because it was a tactic to do a new
year's resolution hence why my first
answer was right which is when you
actually decide to make a change in your
life whether about weight or job or
going out with somebody or relationships
that's when you actually pull it off
it's religion not tactics amazing you
got it
it is
yeah